all right so Matt one of the questions I
have for you is obviously the oil prices
have been dropping very quickly over the
last couple of weeks and we're reaching
a point now where we're going on
multiple weeks of that oil price being
below where most oil producers
especially the United States are not
profitable do you see a world where the
folks who have this oil realize hey
rather than just selling the barrels of
oil I can actually use that to generate
power and I should be mining crypto at a
much more profitable manner or even
maybe some of the other excess power
producers kind of going in as well it's
starting to realize this or do you think
that we're still far away from what I'll
call traditional industry or traditional
energy producers kind of crossing the
chasm into a Bitcoin mining it's you
know that's a great question and it's
it's very specific to the US there's a
group I mean there I want to keep
everyone's stuff confidential but
there's a leader that we've done
business with we respect them he's
really intelligent and they're building
us out in in several states they're
capturing the flare gas there I'd say
that the leaders in it and and there's
excess right now so they're going to
these different oil drillers and they're
working with them they're capturing the
flare gas they're using these natural
gas generators and and the power is very
cheap I have another client we just had
to call them last week it's two two
individuals out west and and they are
doing the same thing to a smaller scale
but they're gonna ramp up because
they've identified the opportunity and
they're gonna capture it they are going
there in there in Texas and they're
capturing the the flare gas they're
connecting it with a natural gas
generator and and they're burning that
and they have one cent electricity it's
this is gonna change mining it brings in
it creates cost efficiencies for these
oil you know the the the the oil
chillers don't have anything to do with
they they don't have anything to do with
the natural
so you either burn it or you know it
doesn't it doesn't store well so that's
why they're utilizing it it's it's it's
basically a byproduct that's being
leveraged so yeah we see an opportunity
there I'm not as proficient as
explaining that because I'm not doing it
but I have clients that are and they're
making exceptional money doing it one
cent electricity and mining Bitcoin so
there's going to be synergies where you
could where you could bring Bitcoin
mining to these fields put down a
container have the natural gas
generators capture the flare gas burn it
or whatever mechanism it is I'm guessing
the national gas generator does that and
and they're achieving 1 cent electricity
and that's funny in the mining rigs and
and that's you know it's it's being very
efficient so and we have a lot of that
in the US the US has the versus the most
energy abundant country in the world I
mean we you look at Texas there's wind
power there's solar there's natural gas
oil they have it all so we're gonna
leverage it and and and and it makes me
very very bullish for Bitcoin yeah so in
the u.s. I mean there's people I think
don't realize there's so much energy
abundancy in the u.s. in Kentucky we're
using hydro there's there's a lot of
hydro in upstate New York Pacific
Northwest
you have Texas has wind solar oil
natural gas just about everything so
that's why I mean--but made I don't know
if people know this bit Maine is mining
in Texas so the Chinese are coming here
you have you have all the stability in
the US with regulation the
municipalities just don't shut you down
overnight you don't have to negotiate
with the politicians it's very you know
if you're gonna if you're gonna allocate
millions of dollars to a mining
operation you know as as a hedge fund
manager you want to assure you can have
a grass for your risk you
want to deploy something in China or
Russia and overnight someone shuts down
your mind right in the u.s. you have
that stability and most importantly you
have redundancy the grid when was the
last time we had a blackout in the US
people are deploying stuff in Venezuela
Iran I think 20% of the day they have
blackouts in the US the bandwidth the
internet connectivity these miners need
to be connected at a hundred percent up
times right so in the u.s. you have a
hundred percent off times in other
countries in the internet might be down
for 15-20 percent there in the year so
you a couple and all these all these
variables the abundancy of energy what
these miners are doing with the natural
gas the exceptional Internet
connectivity the the regulation and
stability it's just a far healthier
environment to be Bitcoin mining and the
numbers show it and that's why the
acceleration the growing market is North
America and it's exceptional for our for
the Bitcoin network because you want
this decentralization we want more hash
in the u.s. we don't want all the ASIC
manufacturers in China and 65% of the
hash in China and the majority of the
pools in China right so we want this
decentralized network it's a significant
value add and it's what you know it's
part of the you know the the the
fundamentals of a Bitcoin